you've got to speak up this thing about
dropping our voice you know i used to go
into movie studios for meetings
and i'd be sitting out in the waiting
room you know you sit for a few minutes
before they call you in and
almost every time somebody would come up
to me and drop his voice and say i i saw
you on hannity i i saw you on back and i
would always say the same thing why are
you whispering you're in the right
hand
and i understand the fear and i
understand you know we we famously had
this uh supposedly secret organization
the friends of abe out in hollywood
and i kept saying to the leaders you
know we've got to go public and they
wouldn't do it because they didn't want
the working guys to get caught the
gaffers and the guys who were not movie
stars and all this but i just thought if
you don't if you if you act in secret
then you look like you're ashamed and if
you act in secret you look like you're
afraid
so as a guy that was around that and
also was around hollywood and and you
know doing movies and clint eastwood
although he's one of the few sane ones
we've got but yeah but you've been
around the machine
what is it have you like been able to
really unpack maybe now that you've
stepped away from it like what is it
that causes that group think amongst
these people who so often seemingly vote
against their own interests they cannot
be happy that the homeless people are
now climbing up the hollywood hills like
we're in walking dead
no it is absolutely true but you know
there's certain things there's certainly
breaks walls between them for instance
in san francisco the rich people are
living in uh silicon valley you know the
rich people are not living in the places
that they let go down the drain there is
you know it's a funny thing because in a
way in a way it's a point that marx karl
marx himself might have made you know
karl marx
basically believed that your wages had
not gone you hadn't become richer if
there was now a bigger divide between
you and the really rich people he
believed that it was all relative you
know so even though you were doing
better if the next guy was doing ten
times better you were going to be
unhappy and there's a lot of human truth
to that i mean that's you know it's envy
it's
covetousness those are just human traits
and so we have got a moment now when
some of these wealthy people are so
wealthy and so detached and so
surrounded by other people like
themselves and so uh disdainful of the
ordinary men and women who just want to
do their jobs and and have some fun and
you know get married and have kids
they're so disdainful of that life that
they really have no idea what people are
talking about some of these people who
are accusing
look i i lived out of the country for
seven years this is the least racist
country on earth it is the least racist
country on earth and when they talk
about systemic racism it's the least
systemic racist country on earth because
obviously they're always going to be
racist people but
they they don't know it they don't know
it when they talk about oh yeah these
people are just racist they believe it
because they never see them they never
meet them they never talk to them they
never listen to them some of the stuff
that you and i talk about
on what is now called conservative uh
media they've never heard they have
never heard it and when they discover it
they're absolutely shocked i mean
russell brown the comedian yeah who was
he was a very very bright guy but he is
kind of left to center when he found out
that the russian collusion thing was a
hoax he went on the air and he said i'm
gobsmacked i'm flabbergasted who knew
well we knew you know we knew and we
said it all the time and a lot of stuff
that we know ultimately becomes
mainstream but they never stop and say
oh gee
the right wingers were telling the truth
and the new york times and cnn and nbc
were all lying they just never say that
uh
think of all the people that they made
into idols andrew cuomo uh you know uh
what was the other guys michael uh
avenatti you know is that was that his
name yeah yeah uh and and now dr fauci
uh you know torturing dogs having eating
the faces
literally like you cannot make this
stuff up eating the faces off dogs that
they don't let their paws go i mean it's
just insane
and these are their heroes and you know
you'd think at some point they would say
hmm maybe we're not that good a judge of
character you know maybe we ought to
take another look at a ted cruz maybe
he's not a bad guy you know maybe maybe
picking on mike pence for being true to
his wife isn't really a great you know
look for us
they never do they never listen to us
they're so separated they're so
sequestered by their wealth and their
cultural power more than anything else
their cultural power has sequestered
them that they do not know what they do
not know and that's basically the kind
of stuff that the rest of us are talking
about you and i don't agree on
everything me and ben shapiro don't
agree and michael knows we all have
these big arguments we have a range of
opinions on the right
they've just got this one opinion but
they hear it again and again and again
and they think everything else is evil
so what's the trick i mean you know when
i do my weekly q and a's on thursday
there's always like 10 questions of the
same variety which is what are the
tricks to to wake up my friend how can i
bring them back i can't get them to sit
down and watch a prageru video or dave
now you're too scary for them
so i assume you're on the scary list too
andrew like what what what are the
tricks you got any tricks i mean you
were around a lot of these people
yeah you know
two two things very important one one is
you you've got to speak up this thing
about dropping our voice you know i used
to go into movie studios for meetings
and i'd be sitting out in the waiting
room you know you sit for a few minutes
before they call you in and
almost every time somebody would come up
to me and drop his voice and say i i saw
you on hannity i saw you on beck and i
would always say the same thing why are
you whispering you're
[Laughter]
you know we we famously had this uh
supposedly secret organization the
friends of abe out in hollywood
and i kept saying to the leaders you
know we've got to go public and they
wouldn't do it because they didn't want
the working guys to get caught the
gaffers and the guys who were not movie
stars and all this but i just thought if
you don't if you if you act in secret
then you look like you're ashamed and if
you act in secret you look like you're
afraid and so all of us because all of
you know it's not just artists who are
part of the culture it's not just media
people everybody is part of the culture
everybody has a little piece of it like
you know a candle in their hand you have
got to speak up you've got to you've got
to say it politely you don't have to
scream at people you don't have to get
in their faces you don't have to be
donald trump you just politely say you
know i disagree and and if if we don't
start doing that if we let them cow us
and silence us we have no choice chance
and the other side of it also is
right-wingers think that the truth is so
important the facts are so important
that you don't have to be nice about
them that you can scream an ugly truth
in someone's face and paul simon said
you know i want you know i don't want
you to lie to me but i want some
tenderness beneath your honesty and
right winger's got to learn that trick
because
the left are ugly they're mean they call
people names they they're disgusting
they cancel people they bully them if we
don't have a sort of civilized attitude
but
when i say civilized that doesn't mean
keeping your mouth shut it means
speaking bravely and clearly in a polite
way
then we're just the same as them it's we
get lost in the crowd so if we don't
develop uh some communication skills uh
and and some courage
you know we'll be lost we'll be swept
away because they own the media you know
it's so funny because i obviously agree
with the sentiment and then there's this
part of me as someone that's you know
sort of new to this thing on the right
let's say that when you see them lie and
lie and lie again and know they're lying
and we know they're lying and everyone
knows the sultan it's in quote and they
just keep going i can somehow see how
decent right wing people that are
moderates really start sounding like
crazy angry kooks because the years go
by you try to rationalize you try to be
open you try to have conversations they
keep lying things keep getting worse
they're dragging you to hell with them
next thing you know you're screaming on
the radio for four hours a day about
whatever it might be so i'm sympathetic
to even though i get your point i am
sympathetic to the people that it sort
of sound like they're nuts at some level
me too because they also gaslight you so
for 30 years they call you racist they
call you sexist your god stinks your
country stinks your history stinks
everything about you stinks then rush
limbaugh comes on the air and he says
well these feminazis and everybody goes
where is the civility where what where
what has happened to the civility in
this country so they gaslight you but if
you listen one of the things that
happened to me when i came back from
england where i was living i i started
listening to rush just to hear what the
fuss was about and he was so happy and
so funny and so kind of sweet natured uh
with all the stuff that he said that i
thought no wait a minute
that all the stuff i heard is untrue and
i want to listen to what this guy has to
say if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell